NARRATOR: The following content
is provided under a Creative
Commons license.
Your support will help
MIT Open OpenCourseWare
continue to offer high quality
educational resources for free.
To make a donation or to
view additional materials
from hundreds of MIT courses,
visit MIT Open OpenCourseWare
at ocw.mit.edu.
CHRIS BOEBEL: So welcome
to the second lab,
which as we promised,
will primarily
focus on audio recording.
Both the specific
technical aspects
of setting up our
audio package, what's
in it, what it can do and also
some general tips on getting
good recordings.
Again, this is not a class
in digital signal processing
or very intense field recording.
We're really going to
focus on the basics of what
you can do to improve the
audio that you record,
and the really fundamental
things that you
need to be thinking about.
So some of you again, as
with the camera, I mean,
if some of you have audio
recording experience
or are very interested in audio,
this may seem like old hat
or very simple to you.
But we're going to be
starting at a basic level that
assumes no prior knowledge.
Before we do that though,
I want to, as we discussed,
go back and take a look
at some of the stuff that
was shot last week.
Some very interesting
choices were made,
and we're going to go
through it and talk
about what worked,
what could be improved,
some of the technical
challenges that were faced.
And then based on
that, we can do
a little bit of a review and
an expansion of various things
you can do with the camera, both
in terms of framing and film
grammar, as we've
been talking about,
as well as technical things.
So I'm going to dive right in.
Put together just a
few clips, all silent.
I took the audio out because
it was all a camera mic and--
Yep.
AUDIENCE: [INAUDIBLE]
CHRIS BOEBEL: Well,
let's find out.
OK, starting right
with a close up.
So if you recall what
the exercise was,
it was film seven or eight
different kinds of things,
including portraits of people.
And this is--
I picked a random sampling.
It's not everything
that everyone shot,
but it's a series of shots that
were interesting for one reason
or that had challenges
for one reason or another.
So this is the first thing.
And this is just, first of
all, in terms of framing,
a really nice portrait.
It's a really nice shot.
I mean, it's very engaging,
it's very interesting,
the framing is nice.
It's a little bit
off center so there's
some energy in the frame.
The challenge, of course, is--
and I should go back--
there are some technical issues,
the primary one being exposure.
And you can see that we're
losing a ton of detail
in the brighter
parts of the frame.
And you were probably a couple
of stops overexposed here.
Now what you can do,
of course, in editing
is attempt to fix that,
bring it down, adjust,
and we can make it look better.
But this is fairly extreme
on the overexposure side.
And it would be, obviously,
a lot better to get it right.
Now what's interesting
is that this is also
kind of an example of
breaking the rules.
I mean, this is a very kind
of dreamy, soft feel to it,
and fashion photography
often has that kind of
blown out whites that
you're looking at here.
But I don't think
this was intentional.
I'm not sure, maybe it was.
It sort of works.
But I would say, concentrate on
getting a good exposure first.
And if you're not
sure of your own skill
at reading, judging exposure
in manual, what you can do
is go to auto exposure and
zoom in on the person's face.
Find out what auto exposure
wants to do, go back to manual,
and then the face is probably
going to be relatively properly
exposed.
It depends on skin
tone of course.
Most cameras are designed
for Caucasian skin tone.
And so if you are filming
people with darker skin tones,
you may want to open up a bit.
Dave?
DAVE STRIPINUS: You can
also use the spot meter.
CHRIS BOEBEL: Yes.
DAVE STRIPINUS: It's
on the second page
of the personal menu.
I think it's the bottom
right, or something like that.
But the spot meter, it acts
a lot like the spot focus.
Once you select it, you use your
finger right on the LCD screen,
and you just press what it
is want to properly expose,
and it will expose that.
And something like this
background would be blown out,
but it's not really what
you care about anyway.
It's all white anyway.
CHRIS BOEBEL: In
most cases, you want
to expose for people's
faces properly, which
is why you can either
zoom in on the face,
get an exposure in auto, or use
the spot meter, pull back out,
and get a decent exposure.
Now, if you're shooting a very,
very wide shot, of course,
that may not be the case.
It may be fine to
underexpose a person's face
in order to get the
environment properly exposed.
And again, it's just the
way these cameras are set up
that they are set up to expose,
as I said, Caucasian skin tone.
So for darker skin
tones, you may
want to open up a 1/2 a
stop, a stop, whatever.
And that's something
that you're going
to have to learn to judge.
But as I said, I mean this is
kind of a very pleasing shot.
The framing is very nice.
A little bit shaky, a
little bit uncertain.
Again, kind of interesting.
Just a very interesting way
of shooting a person I mean,
there's just something.
I like these two shots.
Again, there's an
exposure issue.
I think there's also a bit of
a white balance issue with both
of these, but it's
a little bit hard
to tell because the exposure is
so high that we're also losing
a lot of detail in the color.
So again, think
about those four F's.
White balance, of course,
not being one of the F's,
but the point is that
you need to think
about your technical aspects.
And it just becomes
kind of routine.
Set up the camera, make
sure it's in focus,
make sure it's
properly exposed, think
about what your focal
length is in relation
to this kind of shot
you want to shoot,
make sure that the color
balance, the white balance
is correct.
And you just kind
of run through it,
and then you're ready to go.
But again, both of these
shots are very nice portraits.
So here's another one.
This is an interesting frame.
I like the off-center
nature of the frame.
The big issue here is focus.
And as you can see, her
face is out of focus.
The background is
sharper than the face.
And one of the things
that we're going
to review at the end of this is
ways of getting proper focus.
I think Dave and I kind
of ran through focus
relatively quickly,
and it's worth
reviewing and re-emphasizing.
Because focus, again,
is one of those kind
of non-negotiable items.
There are lots of
rules you can break.
You can overexpose the frame
if you know what you're doing
and you have a
really good reason.
You can frame things
unconventionally.
But focus, it should
always be in focus.
Even if you blur it later, you
really need to shoot in focus.
So that's just kind of a basic.
And we will talk about ways of
making sure that what you want
is in focus, and not
what you don't want.
I mean again here, the issue
is that the background is
sharper than the person's face.
And I think here, I think you
may have been working on that.
Didn't quite come off.
But anyway, we'll
talk about focus
and again, how it just kind
of becomes second nature,
that habit to check focus
on whatever it is that you
want to have emphasized.
We have shambling
giant cruising through.
And both of us are so
awkward on camera, Dave,
you'll see me in a minute.
It's horrible.
DAVE STRIPINUS:
Look like there's
a bridge you're
going to jump off.
Now what's interesting is that
you shot this several times,
and that was great.
The first time,
you see, again, we
talked about where people should
be positioned in the frame.
The camera really wasn't
keeping up with Dave.
He was just really riding
the right side of the frame.
So you were clearly
working on that.
And this one is somewhat better.
CHRIS BOEBEL: It would still
be a more effective shot
if he could always stay
a little bit on the left,
since he's walking to
the right, because it's
just better to show where
the person's heading,
and it gives them more energy,
like that they're moving
into the space on the right.
But it also can be tricky.
Dave, you're not
moving very fast there.
But if people are moving fast,
obviously it can be tricky.
DAVE STRIPINUS: It's
called pushing the frame,
like when it looks like you're
pushing the frame as they walk,
rather than the camera.
CHRIS BOEBEL: Right.
It's like the unresponsive
camera person,
like oh, I didn't expect that.
The other thing, just
to review is headroom.
You can see that it would
be again preferable given
the size of the shot and so on.
If you weren't chopping
the top of his head.
Although it starts out
framed pretty well.
Eyes are up in the top 1/3 here.
The zoom out is a little
shaky, but it's a good idea.
This one's a little
better again.
Also, I love the
reveal of this guy.
What?
Anyway, that was
unintentional, but that there's
a good example of that.
It's a good example of
revealing something.
I mean, this is a classic film
trope that one piece of action
leads into something else
that then reveals itself.
So if in fact Dave was
just an extra in your film
and that guy was
your main character,
and he was freaking out because
he was late for something
and he didn't know
where he was, that
would be kind of an interesting
way to introduce that.
Unintentional, but
again, think about how
you reveal things using
one kind of action
to reveal another or
motion to reveal something.
You don't always have to have
everything square, presented
boom in the frame.
So I think this is kind
of an interesting angle.
I mean, we talked about Varta,
his use of very low, very high,
very different kinds of angles.
This is a not quite as
intense version of that.
But again, it's not head on.
It actually works
really well because you
have these diagonals
going up in the staircase.
And it really emphasizes
what the action
is, this person going
on the ladder, and then
down the stairs.
Now one small thing--
I think I mentioned this
in the first class--
about being decisive
with the camera.
Act like what you're doing even
if you feel that you don't.
And one of the things
that's going on there
is so you see those little
zoom in, the zoom out,
they're very tentative.
Like, should I be tighter?
No, maybe wider?
No, I'm not sure.
And you just have to
act like what you want,
even if you aren't sure.
So if you're thinking,
I want to zoom in here,
you want to start zooming in.
And then until
you find something
that seems worth zooming in
to, and then pull back out.
Zooms are, as
we've talked about,
zooms are kind of tricky.
They're kind of too easy,
and people a lot of people
are just completely
against zooms
when it comes to
documentary work and so on,
just because it's easy
to sit in one place
and just get a bunch
of different shots.
But if you're going to use
that, if you're going to move
the camera in any way, zooming
or panning or hand-held,
you really want to, as I
said, kind of act like what
you're doing, even if you
feel you really don't.
So if I'm shooting this class.
I move over to Dave.
Oh, Dave's not doing
anything interesting.
Well I still did that,
so I'm going to do it.
I'm going to sell that shot.
And if it's a terrible shot,
if he's picking his nose
or something, I'll
bail out of it
as quickly as I possibly can,
and get back to something else.
So I won't don't
waste a lot of time.
What I don't do is,
is that interesting?
Well maybe.
No, oh, he's picking his nose.
Because then I
didn't get anything.
So again, it's just something
that it kind of becomes
second nature.
And did e talk about David
McDougall and the film trance?
I forget.
Do you want to say
something about that?
AUDIENCE: No, I'm not
sure what you have to say.
CHRIS BOEBEL: Oh,
well just there's
a documentary filmmaker,
David McDougall.
And I don't remember if he's
on the reading list this year.
AUDIENCE: [INAUDIBLE]
CHRIS BOEBEL: What's that?
Oh, John Roush?
Oh, film trance.
Oh, OK, I thought that
was-- no, McDougall talks, I
guess he uses a different term.
So anyway, he talks
about it, too.
But so John Roush, a
filmmaker that we'll
be looking at
later in the class,
talks about something that
he calls a cinetrance, which
is basically the mode you get
in when you're shooting a scene.
And a documentary scene, a
scene that you're not really
controlling, where
you're so immersed in it.
And people are kind of
interacting with you,
you're interacting with them.
You're making choices
as the action unfolds
about what you're shooting,
how you choose to shoot it,
the angle you're
choosing to shoot,
the next thing
you're going to do.
And the choices that you make
almost instinctively when
you're that immersed in a scene.
And another way to talk about
it is that whatever you're doing
is right.
It's very spontaneous.
Again, when I say, act like
what you're doing even if you
don't, it's kind of similar.
Because you're
responding to whatever's
happening around you.
And so you can't
make a wrong choice.
If you do make a wrong choice,
you get out of it really
quickly.
But the choice you've
made instinctively,
if you trust yourself, trust
yourself to follow that up.
Why did I want to
pan over to Dave?
Maybe--
AUDIENCE: Just following
up on that film trance,
there is something very
hypnotic about it, which
was part of the discussion.
How do you get so-- and
I have that machine--
but when you do do it and
you get really into it,
it does become kind of like
hypnotic and basically,
they just talk
about, say, people
who do war photography
or war filmmaking,
that they had a sense of
themselves being invincible,
because you get so
caught up in the frame
that you just follow
everything, and it's not
like a normal
experience of the world.
And if you can become
really addictive
to see through the camera frame.
And if you remember
from Varta there's
a discussion with Hal Kaufman,
who was the brother of Varta,
who did a lot of the shooting.
And he went on this vacation,
and he didn't bring his camera.
And he was so disturbed seeing
the world without a camera,
because he'd become so
addicted to seeing the world
to the camera, that
the [INAUDIBLE] him.
So there is just
something really hypnotic
about once you're seeing the
world through this camera eye,
just get kind of caught.
CHRIS BOEBEL: I had
that experience I mean,
I've never done anything
like war photography,
but I was shooting aerobatics
in a light plane at one point.
And we were doing all
these insane, crazy things
that I would have been
absolutely terrified to have
been involved in.
But I was shooting
it, and I didn't care.
I was just like,
whoa, this is amazing.
We're diving and then we're
flying along the highway
a foot off the ground, and
then we're climbing vertically
and rolling.
And it was just great.
I loved it.
But if I had not
had the camera, I
would have been completely
terrified, because that's not
my idea of fun.
So anyway.
So let's moving on.
So this is, we
did the following.
So this is quite a cool shot.
The way it's introduced with
the shadow and then pans up.
Doors locked, of course.
So we tried that several times.
Just full disclosure, I think
the first couple were not
as successful.
So that's another
thing to think about.
If you're interacting
with their subject
and your subject is
cooperative, and it
doesn't work the first few
times, you can keep doing it.
You saw that again
with Dave and the pan.
So it took a few times for
you to work out how would
the shadow reveal the person?
Oh, that didn't work.
Well try something else.
But that was a nice shot.
Another.
Of course, you can't
resist a mirror.
So here we have some
hand-held following.
This is a little shaky,
but quite a nice shot.
And just to talk about
handheld for a moment,
one of the things that
I think we'll do--
I talk about how we're
going to go over focus--
I think we should also talk
about techniques for handheld,
holding the camera,
how to smooth yourself.
So there's that
technical aspect of it,
but then there's also
the choice of how do you
frame your subjects and how
do you choose whether or not
you're going handheld.
And what works about this
is that you're following
a person, first of all.
A handheld shot that could
have better be shot on a tripod
is just a shaky shot, or
potentially shaky shot.
This works because
you're following
a person who's walking.
I mean, it's obvious,
but it's worth saying.
Also it's a wide shot,
and wide focal lengths
work much better in handheld
because they're smoother.
And it's also kind
of a pleasing frame.
You have these
horizontals converging
in the center of the frame.
So here we have
another handheld,
another in our genre of
tripod carrying shots.
This is kind of a little washed
out because of the light.
So again, kind of shaky,
but I mean, going downstairs
is very difficult.
One of the things
that might help
would be paying more
attention to the verticals
and horizontals.
You see, we're at a
real tilted angle here.
What's interesting
about this shot
is that the frame changes a lot.
And this is another
thing that you
can do with a moving
camera that's kind of cool.
So it starts out with kind
of a wide shot of me walking,
and then it turns into
an over-the-shoulder shot
of me walking.
And then the camera
comes around,
and now I'm in a closer shot,
and you're walking backwards.
So one of the reasons to do a
handheld shot or a moving shot
is so that you can make
the frame more fluid.
You can do a wide shot that
turns into a close-up that
turns into an
over-the-shoulder shot that
turns into a medium shot.
And again, what works about
this is that, and the fact
that I'm being followed.
That there's action
in the frame that's
initiating the moving camera.
And my main suggestion
would be first of all,
as I said, to really think about
the verticals and horizontals,
and try to avoid that
seasickness feeling.
There's also an issue
with exposure here.
And this is
something that you'll
have to make a choice about if
you try to do shots like this.
I'm going through all sorts
of different light sources,
and all sorts of different
levels of exposure.
It's very dark, then
it's very bright,
then it's very dark again.
And what we did was
we picked one exposure
and we stayed on that.
So you can see that
sometimes I'm underexposed,
sometimes I'm overexposed,
the windows are blown out.
And the issue for
you to think about--
and there are actually
reasons to do both--
is do you want to
do it that way,
do you want to leave
the camera on auto--
the problem with that being that
the camera will start breathing
and changing sometimes
when you don't want it to.
Or do you want to manually
change your exposure as you go?
So you could start out
at a much higher f-stop,
and then you could stop down
as the bright light hits
the camera.
And then when you come
around the corner here,
you could open the iris again.
And you would have to do
that manually while you were
walking, which is a trick
to learn, especially
with these little cameras
and the little iris.
But it's a choice to make.
Which do you want to do?
It's going to really depend on
your preference as a filmmaker,
and exactly what kind of
shot you're going for.
So here we have
another following shot.
There's a bit of a white
balance issue here.
So we're a bit orange.
I think we've come
in from outside.
So what I like about
that shot is the fact
that you start out
in a very wide shot
and come into a close-up.
And that's really powerful.
That's a very simple way
of introducing a character.
I see that sign, I go, hey,
you're the main character.
I'm following this guy.
This is great.
So that's really powerful.
There are also some
kind of neat frames.
And the frame is
changing in a nice way.
I mean, you're showing off
the architecture of Stata
and that staircase,
which is quite striking.
And then as I said,
it's starting out
in a very wide shot and
coming into a close-up.
White balance again,
you change your shot,
you should always check
your white balance.
I mean, unless it's
really the same lighting,
you want to change it.
Certainly if you come in to the
interior from being outside,
you need to re-white balance.
Even within an
environment like Stata,
where you've got
overheads and big windows
and all sorts of mixed lighting
situations, if you change,
you want to check
the white balance.
Because parts of
Stata are almost
like daylight,
and parts of Stata
are a very different
color temperature,
because they have fluorescents.
They might have halogens.
I mean, there's all sorts of
crazy stuff going on in there.
So you want to change
and check every time.
So here we have
filming an activity.
So this is a close-up,
or what we call sometimes
an insert shot.
Nice shot.
So the only thing there is
you had a really nice shot,
and you just hold it.
Don't worry about changing it.
It was working really well.
And then suddenly
there was that decision
to like, oh, wait, why go wide.
Oh, wait, I'm going
to not go wide.
And again, everyone does that.
I mean, even very experienced
camera people do that.
But making a choice
and sticking with it
is some of the best
advice I can give.
So if the choice there was to
go wide, go all the way wide.
Show the whole scene.
And then after you've done
that for a few seconds,
if that seems to have been
maybe the wrong choice,
you can go back in.
But going back and forth,
censoring yourself, going,
I want to be wide.
Oh no, I want to be close.
And it's not just zoom.
I mean, I've shown a couple
of examples of zooms.
But again, I want to show Chris.
No, I want show Dave.
No, I want to show Sabrina.
That is how you end
up with nothing.
So here we have another zoom.
And again, I'm not
a huge fan of zooms.
But that one kind of
works because it's
revealing something.
Again, there's an
exposure issue.
It's overexposed.
But you have this
group of people,
and you're revealing the
sculpture and the environment.
Now this is a very pretty
shot which again, is
marred by that indecisiveness.
So I could imagine
that same shot
being this very beautiful
environmental shot, just
with a more decisive
tilt up and tilt down.
So you could be doing a
very nice, smooth tilt
up to the sky.
You could go all
the way to the sky.
Or you could come
down from the sky,
reverse it, and find
the people walking.
But whatever you do,
you want to be decisive
so that you don't have that
uncertainty in the camera.
See what I'm talking about.
Should I start?
OK, I think, I will.
Where am I going?
I'm not sure.
But again, very
pretty idea of a shot.
And here we have a really
great shot, nice self-portrait.
The only thing I
would say about that,
again, there's a little bit
of indecisiveness at the end.
And it's the kind of
shot that would probably
be better on a tripod.
I mean, there may have
been a time issue.
Like oh, well you
see this thing,
and you don't want to set
up the tripod, and so on.
And sometimes that's
understandable.
But if you have time, you
see a great shot like that,
if you set up the tripod,
you'll have the same shot
and it'll just be nice
and much smoother.
Because the energy or
shakiness of the handheld frame
there doesn't really
add to the shot.
But it's great.
It's a very pretty
idea for a shot,
and it and it's a nice
review of you guys working.
So here we have,
I'm going to end
with a couple of
voyeuristic shots.
This one, I mean there's
an exposure issue
and a white balance issue.
But I included it because it
feels a little bit voyeuristic.
And the reason for
that is that it's
shot on a long lens,
so everything's
kind of compressed.
It feels like the camera is
far away from the action.
So imagine shooting that same
two dogs at play on a wide lens
where you're right
up in the action.
It would feel really,
really different.
Whether you were
handheld or wide,
it would feel much more
intimate, much more
like the camera people were
connected to the action.
More like, you knew these
dogs, you knew the owners,
you were part of the activity.
That is, I mean it's
a cool shot, aside
from the technical
issues, and sometimes you
may want to do
this intentionally.
It pushes us away
from the action.
It feels like we're kind
of viewing it from afar,
because literally, we are.
And speaking of voyeurism.
So I included that again
because first of all,
it's a very interesting
example of a rack focus,
like revealing
something with focus.
And secondly, because
it feels so voyeuristic,
obviously because
of the activity.
But also because of
the way it's framed.
It's a long lens, we focus into
it, you see this little moment,
and then we fade out.
So it's actually it's
very successful as a shot,
but it's a very specific way,
a very specific emotional way
of looking at that scene.
I mean, again, imagine
if you were right down
there with the people,
filming them kissing.
That would be really
different, because would there
be an implicit consent
that you were there,
they were there, that there
was much more intimacy.
This is, for better or worse
very, very, very distant.
And it's cool.
I mean, it works.
I'm not saying it doesn't work.
I'm saying it gives you a
very specific emotional read
of the situation, and the
camera's relationship.
Is that kiss more
elicit than the kiss
that you would
have filmed closer?
It feels a lot more elicit.
And then the last shot
here, the Kino eye,
think this is a very cool shot.
This was our OpenCourseWare
camera person.
So I thought that was
a very pretty shot,
and a nice way to end it.
So anyway, any thoughts or
questions about any of this
stuff?
Ideas?
Concerns?
OK, so what I thought
we would do next,
and it's going to take a
minute or two to set up,
is just talk a little bit
about some of the things
that came up in this stuff.
We're going to try to hook
up a camera to the projector.
I can show you a
couple of things
that you can be thinking
about when you shoot.
And then we're going to talk
a bit more about film grammar
before we switch over to audio.
So let's see, I guess
I should unplug this.
Yeah, I mean this won't
take too long, but--
Here we go.
OK, so let's just start talking
about setting up a shot here.
I mean, this is not a
very appealing shot.
The white balance is wrong.
DAVE STRIPINUS:
It's a good chance
to talk about
angles, if you shoot
from below rather than above.
CHRIS BOEBEL: Well yeah,
but let's first talk
about white balance
and exposure.
Because this is not happening.
So how would I fix this?
First thing I want
to do, of course,
is make sure that my
white balance is correct.
If I don't have
a piece of paper,
I can grab something else.
So that is probably
close enough for now.
Second thing I might want to
do is get a rough exposure.
So I'm exposing up.
Now what exactly my exposure is
here might depend on my frame,
and I'll show you what I mean.
If I zoom in on
Dave, I get my focus.
And I may want to expose
more if I'm really going
to be in close up on Dave.
DAVE STRIPINUS: I
also have an odd face.
They get those shadows under
the eyes because of my eye.
CHRIS BOEBEL: Oh,
stop making excuses.
All right, so this would be
like a close-up, potentially.
It's a really tough
lighting situation.
I might ask Dave to move
if I felt like I could,
depending on the environment.
Yeah, I'm afraid too, though.
So if I go out
wide again, see now
it looks really overexposed.
So again, I'm going to adjust
my exposure a little bit.
What's really killing me is
the backlight of the window.
So what I could say
is, excuse me, sir?
Could you take a step just
a little forward please?
Thank you.
And now
DAVE STRIPINUS:
Chris, you're in--
CHRIS BOEBEL: I'm sorry.
So now it's a little bit easier
to get a proper exposure.
So the trick with
focus, which I don't
think we emphasized
enough last week,
is that if you're in a
tough focus situation,
or pretty much in any
situation, what you want to do
is zoom in and get focus.
And in the case of shooting
people, what you want
to be in focus are the eyes.
And then you can zoom
back out to whatever frame
it is that you wanted to have.
So even if I'm way out here--
and here I might want
to go down in terms
of my exposure a little bit--
his eyes are what I cared
about being in focus.
And again, if I
come over here, I
might want to rechange
my white balance.
Because this is a
very mixed situation.
Dave is much more in
daylight over here
than he would be over here.
So I might want to change
my white balance again.
And remember again,
the white balance
is set to the assign button
on the right of the camera.
So I'm going to zoom
in on a piece of paper.
AUDIENCE: [INAUDIBLE]
CHRIS BOEBEL:
Well, I mean, yeah,
bring white paper with you.
DAVE STRIPINUS:
Looks a little blue.
CHRIS BOEBEL: That really
does look blue, doesn't it?
Doesn't seem like a
very good white balance.
DAVE STRIPINUS: Do you want
me to hold a piece of paper?
CHRIS BOEBEL: Yeah, right.
The table was not a really
good choice, actually.
But this seems-- anyway.
AUDIENCE: [INAUDIBLE]
CHRIS BOEBEL: Then everything
will be off by that percent.
So yeah, what Dennis
mentioned was that this,
I set it to a table here,
which isn't really white.
It's got a little bit
of yellowish in it.
So I'm fooling the
camera a little bit.
And you can do
that intentionally,
but it's probably better
to do that kind of thing
in post-production.
DAVE STRIPINUS: If you
get an approximation
it's pretty easy to fix
white balance in post.
CHRIS BOEBEL: And yeah, some
of the things that we just
looked at that were off
probably are somewhat fixable.
So that looks better.
So again, this is a
different white balance
than the other side of the room.
Now one thing that
Dave was talking about,
we talked about camera angles
a lot on Wednesday night.
We talked about Varta, we
talked about Nanook of the North
and the way the camera
gets used in both of those.
And to go back to Dave
here for a minute,
think about the difference
between this shot,
and this shot, and this shot.
Giant Dave Stripinis.
Giant of film here.
And then this is the
flare-outty, I know this guy,
I'm going to I'm
going to learn more
about this guy kind of feeling.
And this is the spy
cam, voyeuristic,
make Dave look
small kind of thing.
So how you choose-- and
that's just one example--
but how you choose
your shots throughout,
and whether you're choosing
to be on a tripod or handheld,
how you're moving the camera,
has an emotional resonance.
It's very important.
So do you want to just go
over the basic controls again
of the camera,
just one last time?
I don't if you want to have
this plugged in or out.
DAVE STRIPINUS: You can you
leave it plugged in, it's cool.
CHRIS BOEBEL: And then
we'll talk a little bit
about putting shots together.
DAVE STRIPINUS: I mean,
it's again, just the basics.
The zoom is in the back
right of the camera.
So you can go tight,
you can go wide.
It's also right here
on the LCD screen,
if you want to zoom in, Denis.
Last time I didn't hold
positions long enough.
That's good.
So on the actual LCD
screen, you can see a W
and a T wide and telephoto.
It's a much slower,
controlled zoom.
This is pressure
sensitive in the back,
so it depends on the situation
which one you want to use.
The focus ring, I would just
keep this switch right here
all the way on the
back on manual focus,
because this is the
only ring you have.
A lot of cameras
have three rings.
They have one for aperture,
one for focus, one for zoom.
But since this is the sole,
the only ring you have,
I would keep this for
focus and just use zoom
on the back right
or on the LCD panel.
Again, exposure is right here.
The lever-- sorry.
If for some reason
or another you're
not getting the focus
bar in the LCD screen,
there's a little button
right behind the lever.
And just press that.
So I pressed it now, and I
have no control over exposure.
But if you press it
again, you get the access
to the focus lever or
the exposure lever.
I think this button
right here switches
between volume control.
You can use this
for volume control
or you can use it for exposure.
So if it's never
working correctly,
you're not changing
the exposure at all,
just press the little
button that's behind it.
And that should
fix your problem.
Let's see, should
I do menu options?
CHRIS BOEBEL: Well maybe just--
when I picked up that camera
today, it was set in all auto.
So it might be just good to talk
about how you get out of auto.
Because one of the
things that you may find
is that it's in auto focus,
it's in auto white balance,
it's an auto exposure.
DAVE STRIPINUS: Oh, this is
the one we used on the screen.
CHRIS BOEBEL:
That's right, yeah.
So if you happen to get
a camera like that that's
been set that way, it's good
to know pretty quickly how
to get out of that.
So let's just do that,
and then I'll move on.
DAVE STRIPINUS:
Right here, the one
that you set for manual focus,
there are three options.
You can put it all the
way to the back, which
is manual focus.
You can put it in the
middle, which is auto focus.
So let's just assume, can
I use you for an example,
[? Anna? ?] Let's
just zoom in here.
And if I-- oh, that's right.
Let me just mess with the focus.
Let's put it on auto
focus, and there you go.
So if you're ever
in a situation,
like say you're
doing handheld stuff
and you're working hard
to follow somebody,
you may want to use auto focus.
If you're staying
wide and you're
following that person in
a relatively close manner.
So in some instances it's good
to have, but for the most part
I would recommend manual focus.
CHRIS BOEBEL: Do you need
hat again for a wide shot--
I got the detail of
your hands, and now I
want to show the
screen, as well.
DAVE STRIPINUS: Oh yeah, sure.
So I'm going to put it on
manual focus and just mess
up the focus.
And once you switch
it to auto focus,
it snaps right into focus.
At the front of this
three switch is zoom,
and you can set
this ring right here
to zoom if you push this
all the way to the front.
And now this ring
acts as a zoom ring.
So again, I would
keep this on focus,
manual focus at the very back.
On the right hand side
of the camera again,
the assign button is right here.
And this is for white balancing.
So again, find a
white sheet of paper.
If you're with
somebody else, just
have them hold it up to whatever
your dominant light source is.
Zoom in, try to fill the frame
about 80% with the white paper,
press this assign button, and
it should white balance for you.
You should see a little
blinking what looks
like a flower in the LCD panel.
When it's done
blinking, that means
you're properly white balanced.
And of course, you'll
see the color change
in the actual LCD screen.
So let's see, other
auto features.
You have to go into
the menu a little bit.
Actually, I think you have to go
to the main menu for exposure.
And you can't really
mirror it here.
In the main menu, not
the personal menu,
if you want to go
to auto exposure,
which is a good idea if you're
leaving the camera alone
and you're going to have a
lot of changes in lighting.
If you go to camera set--
I don't if you can, this
might be a little weird--
camera set in the main
menu, not the personal menu
but the bigger menu.
And you go to exposure, you
have a choice of auto or manual.
And if you're just going to
set the camera up on a tripod--
and again, it's
going to be changes
in the lighting in the
room, I would go with auto.
What else?
CHRIS BOEBEL: Yeah, in
the second half of class,
everyone is going to get the
sound package and the camera
package, and practice
working with them together.
And that also might
be a good time for you
to just look at some
of these settings
again, and talk to
either Dave or I
if you have questions
or aren't sure about how
to get from one kind
of setting to another,
or how to do focus and
exposure, a white balance.
It's going to take a
little bit of practice
until it becomes kind
of second nature.
So before we move
over to sound--
and we'll take a quick
break before we do that--
I want to talk a little bit more
about putting shots together,
what we've been kind of
calling film grammar.
So thinking back to the films
that we looked at on Wednesday
night, what kinds of
shots were they using?
Give me some ideas of the
kinds of things we saw.
AUDIENCE: [INAUDIBLE]
CHRIS BOEBEL: Right, so
wide shots, we'll call them.
What else?
AUDIENCE: Like some close-ups.
CHRIS BOEBEL:
Close-ups of people.
What else?
AUDIENCE: Medium shots.
CHRIS BOEBEL: Medium shots.
Right, which is kind
of the in-between.
So what about Varta, how was he
using the camera differently?
AUDIENCE: [INAUDIBLE]
CHRIS BOEBEL: Right,
extreme angles.
Any of these could also
be an extreme angle,
but that's definitely
worth putting up here.
In Nanook, there's the
scene with the fishing.
What other kinds of shots
did you see in that scene,
if you remember?
AUDIENCE: Back and forth
between far away and zoomed in.
CHRIS BOEBEL: Right.
Now, it was also zooming in--
and I don't think actually
zoomed, but it's like--
AUDIENCE: It was like focus
on the fish, and then--
CHRIS BOEBEL: Yes, so
focusing on the fish
is a different kind of shot.
And that has different names,
but what I'll call it for now
is what's often referred
to as the insert shot.
And what that means
is you insert it
in the middle of the action to
show a close-up of an activity.
So for instance, the shot of
paying for the food in the line
is kind of an insert shot.
And it's definitely
worth putting up here.
DAVE STRIPINUS: Do you want
to tie that into coverage?
CHRIS BOEBEL: That's
where I'm going.
Yeah.
So anything else?
Think about Varta.
Think about the shots of
the people in the carriage,
the train's--
AUDIENCE: Moving.
CHRIS BOEBEL: Right.
Moving shots.
And that could be handheld,
like we were doing,
or it could be a fixed shot.
It could be what we call
a dolly shot, except we
don't have a dolly.
But if you could be mounted
in a car, as Varta was.
You could be mounted on
a train or a streetcar.
The generic term for that might
be a dolly shot, with the idea
being that would be smoother
than a hand-held shot,
because you're on some kind of
wheeled vehicle on a tripod,
probably.
So this is not at all a
mutually exclusive list.
I mean, a moving shot
could be a wide shot.
It could be a close-up.
It could be a medium shot.
It could even be an insert shot.
Extreme angles, could
be any of these.
Handheld, you could have
a handheld wide shot,
a handheld close-up.
So this is not an
exclusive list,
but if you look at these, wide
shot, close-up, medium shot,
insert shot, that's
going to cover
a lot of the kind of thing that
you're going to be shooting.
And they fit together in very
specific and particular ways.
And that's what we really
refer to as film grammar.
And these other things, as
I said, all of these things
could be one of these
or anything else.
So I'll pick up the
camera in a minute.
But let's say we're filming a
scene of two people talking,
and I'm drawing
it from overhead.
These are their noses.
OK.
So how might we
shoot that scene?
AUDIENCE: Just stay on one
side and the [INAUDIBLE]
CHRIS BOEBEL: Right.
So what you're referring
to is what is typically
referred to as the line.
And this is kind of a basic
concept in filmmaking, which
sounds like you're familiar
with, but the rest of you
may not be.
The idea of the line
is that whatever scene
you're shooting, whether it's
a simple scene of two people,
or even one person, or a
more complicated scene,
you draw an imaginary line
through the center of it
like that.
And that axis gives you
a frame of reference
to shoot the scene.
And as long as you stay on one
side or the other of the line,
the shots that you
shoot make sense
when they are put together.
That's kind of in editing.
So what I mean by that is,
let's say we come down here,
if you can see that, and film
a wide shot from the side
of the two people talking.
So if we do that, person
one is looking camera right,
they're looking to the
right side of the lens,
and person two is
looking to the left.
Now if I put the camera
anywhere else along that axis,
or along the side
of the axis, they're
still going to be looking
the same direction.
So I could come over here
and film over their shoulder,
and they're still
looking camera right.
Less so, but still.
And they're still
looking camera left.
I could come over here
and do the same thing.
Can shoot close-ups, I
can shoot wide shots.
If they were working
at something together,
I could shoot insert
shots of whatever
it is that they're doing.
And the hands would still be
all oriented the same way.
Person one is always
oriented to the right,
and person to is
oriented to the left.
But if I come over here, if
I cross the line and start
shooting on this
side, all of a sudden,
it's completely flipped.
Person one is now
looking to the left.
And in editing, the
standard form of editing
is that that is considered
jarring or confusing.
It doesn't flow as
smoothly if you start
cutting those shots together.
Now in 2011, those rules are
really not hard and fast rules.
I mean, Quentin Tarantino
started crossing the line--
well, he wasn't the first.
But at this point in
terms of filmmaking,
we accept all sorts
of things, and we
don't worry as much about it.
But when you're starting
out figuring out
how to shoot
scenes, I think it's
important to know these
rules and then later learn
how to break them.
So let's just quickly--
can we set the camera up?
Let me show you what I mean.
It's probably easier.
So Dennis, I'm
blocking you, right?
AUDIENCE: Right now, yeah.
CHRIS BOEBEL: Come over here.
OK, so Dave and
[INAUDIBLE],, can I
have guys do our little scene?
Let's say you're talking.
And I'm going to come
around here, simply
because if you could
just orient yourselves
so the window is not behind you.
Just-- great.
Dave, a little more this way.
Yeah.
DAVE STRIPINUS: See
any good movies lately?
AUDIENCE: [INAUDIBLE]
DAVE STRIPINUS: Which ones?
CHRIS BOEBEL: OK, so you
see Dave is looking camera
left, and she's
looking camera right.
Dave is looking camera left,
she's looking camera right.
She's still looking
camera right.
I live
DAVE STRIPINUS: Another Year
is playing at the [INAUDIBLE]..
CHRIS BOEBEL: Dave is
looking camera left.
Dave is looking camera left.
And if they were
actually working together
on some kind of activity,
they would still
be looking the same way.
So my line, it goes through
the center of the scene,
just as we described.
If I come over here,
all of a sudden,
suddenly she's
looking camera left.
Because I crossed the line.
DAVE STRIPINUS:
Oh, I missed that.
Yeah.
CHRIS BOEBEL: So that's the
basic concept of the line.
And it can get confusing if you
have a very complicated scene.
Like again, imagine
this classroom.
Imagine somebody up here talking
and the rest of you listening.
If I stay on this
side of the classroom,
this person is always
looking to the right,
and everyone here is
looking to the left.
Dennis is shooting to the left.
But if I go over there, all
of a sudden it's reversed.
So that's kind of the basic
concept of film grammar.
And as I said, it's
broken all the time.
Sometimes intentionally,
sometimes unintentionally.
And people have gotten a lot
more used to reading scenes
when it's broken.
But it's kind of
still a basic thing
that you want to
get familiar with
and you want to use to film
your basic scenes before you
understand how to not do it,
or when it's good to not do it.
One example of when you
might want to change
would be to change
the feel of a space,
if you're shooting the
same space for a long time.
So for instance, if I was doing
a documentary on this class,
and I was in here for
three hours, at some point
I might change on purpose
so that I create a kind
of a new feeling in the class.
So maybe I would
film the camera part
looking this way with the film
grammar set up on this axis.
And then maybe when
we switch to sound,
I go over there
and film this way.
Although these windows
might dictate my choice.
This would be a very
difficult background.
But in other words, you can
change and you can switch,
but that's also a situation
in which I probably
wouldn't be intercutting
the first stuff that I
shot with the second
stuff that I shot.
So it's just a way of
helping your audience just
feel comfortable in the scene,
understand where people are,
accept everything.
And although there are
plenty of times that you may
want to intentionally break it.
So did that make sense?
Questions?
Want to add anything?
DAVE STRIPINUS: No,
I think that's good.
CHRIS BOEBEL: OK.
The only other thing
that I'll talk about just
quickly is focal length.
I mean, I talked a bit
about that voyeuristic
feel that you get
with a long lens.
That is one issue
to think about.
And again, remember that the
focal length that you shoot on
is not the same as
the size of the shot.
So I'm right now shooting
as wide as I possibly can.
And now I'm shooting
a close-up, because I
went to a very long lens.
DAVE STRIPINUS: Is
the study shot on?
CHRIS BOEBEL: Oh, probably not.
No, it's not.
That's OK.
However, I can also
shoot a close-up
on a very wide lens, which
will have a different feel.
For one thing, it's smoother
if you're shooting handheld,
but it also tends to
change people's faces.
Long lenses are actually very
flattering to the human face.
So if you want to
make people look good,
shooting on a longer
lens is a good idea.
It also changes the
relationship between foreground
and background.
You see all of a
sudden the background
is completely in focus?
Which means that we are less
likely to pick out the face.
If I come back here and
go back to a long lens,
the background
starts to get soft.
And you can see how
shaky it is, too.
The steady shot isn't on either.
Now I don't have
enough room in here,
but the other thing that
you can do, of course,
is have a wide shot
that's on a long lens.
If I got back
another 50 yards, I
could have a nice wide shot of
this room on the farthest, most
telephoto focal length.
And that is when you
start to get into kind
of voyeuristic territory.
I mean, think again
about that shot
through the bars of the Kissing.
That was shot-- it's a widish
shot shot on a long lens.
But again, your depth of
field is very shallow.
So you can do things like
rack focus in and out.
It can be very, very
beautiful way to shoot things,
but it has a particular
emotional kind of feeling.
So thoughts, questions about
this stuff before we take
a break and switch into sound?
AUDIENCE: Are you also using a
long lens when using long lens?
CHRIS BOEBEL: But zoomed in.
And this camera
zoomed all the way in,
the longest focal length,
meaning the field of view
of the lenses, as narrow
as it can possibly be.
Right, well so let's
take a 5-minute break.
And then when we
come back, we'll
do a quick introduction to audio
recording and an introduction
to our audio package.
And then we'll get a chance to
spend some time playing around
with both the camera
and the audio gear.